[Musique]
il
via le bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans la région la plus
occidentale de la russie dans l'oblast
de kaliningrad un petit coin totalement
isolée du reste du pays
elle est entourée par la lituanie et la
pologne et elle est bordée par la mer
baltique le pays de lambres a toujours
séduit les états voisins il a appartenu
successivement à l'allemagne puis à
l'urss à la suite de la seconde guerre
mondiale aujourd'hui quel ingrate
témoignent de ces différentes époques
voici des maisons à colombages allemand
voici des traces de la période
soviétique d'ailleurs jusqu'à
l'effondrement de l'urss la ville
étaient fermés aussi bien aux citoyens
soviétiques qu'aux étrangers et voici un
exemple d'architecturé moderne
mais le coeur de la ville c'est l'île de
quand car c'est ici qu'a vécu le grand
philosophe allemand emmanuel kant
pendant la majorité de sa vie
de nos jours la population de
kaliningrad ne cesse d'augmenter des
russes comme des étrangers viennent pour
s'y installer
notre héros du jour vient du nouveau
monde il est parti du canada pour
s'établir dans cette ville pleine
d'histoire il s'appelle d'avengers et il
est chocolatier allons faire sa
connaissance
à l'hélium
comment tu vas sara schüpbach besoin de
te voir est content d'être à kalingrad 1
ça fait plaisir d'être ici pour m
expliquer un petit peu pourquoi
kaliningrad comment on se serait qu'est
ce qui se passe là bas j'ai installé mon
usine en usine ici à 3 1 ah ouais je
fabrique du chocolat oh oui on y
prennent l'europe d'habitude sauf
aujourd'hui
l'électorat et beaucoup maillard
qui viennent moscou je m'attendais à un
petit peu plus de chaleur et d'ajouter
c'est la mer le soleil mais aujourd'hui
non c'est gris et donc tu as fait tu as
mis ton usine de chocolat ici où s à 5
minutes d'ici du centre ville on m'a
botté s'était pas content non je suis
pas contre ok
à
je conviens en superficie
le cal est beaucoup plus gras mais non
loin 1400 m² la menthe et de la dhr pop
la production pour combien d'employés à
peu près sa défense est super
saisonniers ok elle était on est quatre
l'hiver on dit ça
je sais c'est plus plus produit dans
chocolate haut de gamme plus plus pour
des saisonniers alors c'est pour le jour
2 rangs puis le jour des femmes puis le
reste du temps c'est parce que y et
pourquoi kaliningrad a pu être dangereux
si tu étais mouskouri gt3 moscou câline
great une tournée comme experian qas pas
d'impôts sur les bénéfices on paie
beaucoup moins de charges sur les
employés on ne paie pas de taxes à
l'importation sur
les ingrédients de
matériel de production aux niveaux au
niveau fiscal c'est intéressant c'est
intéressant news qu'un accord puis
l'entreprise et beaucoup orienté sur
l'exportation alors c'est beaucoup plus
facile à partir d'ici aussi alors
on aucune taxe à l'importation 80
magasins calingaert je peux pas de de
tva donc c'est un avantage
essentiellement jusqu'à l'escale et le
chocolat alors comment comment on tombe
dans le chocolat quand en temps il faut
faire attention de ne pas tomber un
chocolat au niveau de l'éducation je
suis je suis docteur en théologie
jamais étudié je voulais pas faire de
mes études puis de la théologie une
profession parce que bon je considère
que
la fois ci de voix cela ne doit pas
devenir une source de revenus non j'ai
commencé à proposer dans 10 entreprises
canadiennes de les aider à s'établir à
trouver des représentations des
représentants russie oui puis petit à
petit
par l'entremise de contact
j'ai été mis en contact avec un discours
commun puis j'ai un contrat par une
heure il dit des conneries au chocolat
métallisé pitt qui brille
dans la russie des années 90 était le
principal il s'est à lisieux cris brit
va devenir mon directeur au
développement peut-être avait déjà une
connaissance sur le culinaire dont je
vais aller au salon du chocolat puis je
compte que je connaissais
[Musique]
je dis ok sa compagne est devenu leader
du marché je gagne le premier prix au
sein du chocolat puis ma carrière était
fait foi et c'est comme ça qu'on arrive
ici alors
je voulais avoir je vais faire un
produit dont je puisse être fier bon
devant mon père dont la personne en
france qui m'a après faire du chocolat
puis j'ai décidé bon ben je demande ma
compagnie alors dis j'suis pour
vous à dix mois un thème toujours le
chocolat depuis tout ce temps oui
j'adore le chocolat c'est quelque chose
va j'ai toujours aimé chocolat c'est
vraiment quelque chose que je fais pour
le plaisir parce que c'était plus c'est
un peu plus rentable pour moi de
travailler comme employé six humain
c'est difficile de marine pmm puis
surtout avec les histoires de kovy
depuis les sanctions avec la russie
écoute moi aussi j'aime le chocolat tu
veux pas me faire goûter un petit peu
oui oui
ok
[Musique]
est ce que tu peux m'expliquer d'où
viennent tous les ingrédients le cacao
il vient d'où alors le chocolat si c'est
pour les tablettes on prend les
meilleurs hôtes origines qu'on peut
trouver en allant du venezuela du
vietnam pensée pour les chocolats bas
des fois je bloque le chocolat cache la
rom du fourrage sur un fourrage ou au
cognac avec des airs elle mais je vais
prendre un chocolat africains qui voient
pas masquer mon fourrage alors on
accepte de balancer pour chaque chocolat
d'avoir le goût idéal lequel était
spécialité dans ce chocolat juste notre
vitalité ont épaulé seulement d'affaires
mais je suis vraiment un spécialiste des
ganaches avec l'alcool parce que c'est
le produit naturel numéro il n'y a pas
d'agent de conservation mais j'ai appris
à le travailler pour qu'il soit vraiment
instable
puis à
la lame en chocolat la façon dont on
travaille de la coke et pour que pour
éviter l'évaporation et tous ont fait
des trucs que personne ne ferment puis
cette touche personnelle ans et we wish
emballer les ganaches détruit je pense
qu'on est vraiment les meilleurs romans
aujourd'hui la tout ce que tu as ça
s'est fait en combien de temps combien
qu'elle a été c'est un investissement
qu'elle a été
gg over la compagnie j'ai commencé en
2015 ami mais c'est un investissement de
toute une vie parce que ça fait depuis
98 que je suis dans le chocolat puis
ce que j'ai gagné comme salaire pendant
15 ans j'ai pas d'appartement tout est
dans ma compagnie tuifly line comme on
dit au québec ou à sa façon la compagnie
aussi alors c'est un investissement qui
est difficile à chiffrer c est en fait
tous toutes les recettes c'est toi qui
les créent c'est moi qui fais les
recettes du marketing et de la
technologie sous des finances c'est pme
version
complètement complètement dedans à fond
tous les jours webb a des fois même
j'aimerais l'être un peu moins mais
c'est la vie je vais te montrer deux
produits dont je suis particulièrement
fier mais d'abord je vais te présenter à
une personne qui qui mon soutien moral
l'effectif professionnel cathy qui
travaillent avec moi puis un petit
bonjour cathy au cente enchanté mais je
t'avais dit que j'avais une en théologie
oui c'est un produit que j'ai développé
avec un prêtre de saint pétersbourg qui
s'occupe de la jeunesse puis en france
vous avez le grandry de l'avant oui oui
chaque symbole c'est aussi un symbole
qu'on a pris de l'antiquité chrétienne
puis c'est pas seulement qu'un
calendrier tu ouvres tulle et puis tu
toute l'histoire d'accord c'est ça
qu'est ce que c'est ça c'est notre botte
de truffer ses ennuis frontières du
kremlin alors c'est une truffe qui écrit
pour qu'on ait besoin de la tournée dans
lomé puis
qui a pas de coquille alors c'est une
ganache pure
on peut goûter mais je vais donner
l'autre à cathy
chine
[Musique]
dave est énergique il est passionné par
son travail
disons qu'il est créatif volontaire
les rêveurs ils aiment essayer de
nouvelles choses il est toujours en
train d'inventer quelque chose de
nouveau goût de nouveaux produits il
fait des expériences lui même dans le
laboratoire ensuite il nous fait douter
ils nous demandent si c'est bon
[Musique]
c'est des années d expérience quoi ouais
ça fait 25 ans que je cherche
des managers est né en 1977 à larouche
dans le nord du canada il passe son
enfance dans un environnement rustique
son père est chef cuisinier et sa mère
est serveuse il a aussi une soeur aînée
à 18 ans il part étudier à l'université
laval au québec il est admis à la
faculté de théologie et se spécialisant
patrologie byzantine c'est cette
recherche qui le pousse à s'intéresser à
la russie du coup des vessies de faire
connaissance avec ce pays et il vient
dans le cadre d'un programme des changes
il s'inscrit comme étudiant libre à
l'académie théologique de moscou et
étudie pendant un an
il revient ensuite au canada et se met à
planter des arbres pour payer ses dettes
d'étudiants mais son lien avec la russie
persiste de 1999 à 2001 il sert
d'intermédiaire entre des producteurs
canadiens et leurs distributeurs russes
en 2001 on marchait du souvenir ismaïlov
ski à moscou dave rencontre sa future
femme une russe avec qui il aura deux
enfants dès lors il s'installe en russie
et intègre une entreprise de vente de
bijoux il en profite pour convaincre son
chef de se lancer dans le business du
chocolat cette filière passionne dave de
plus en plus et c'est après une
rencontre avec le chocolatier russe
qu'aucun off qui se fait engager comme
directeur du développement
malgré son manque d'expérience un manque
que dave ses forces aussitôt de combler
il se met à développer de nouvelles
recettes et fait un stage dans la
manufacture de cluzel en 2005 il
remporte le premier prix du salon du
chocolat de paris avec sa propre
création il passe chez wim bill dames où
il crée une gamme de desserts laitiers
mais cherche plus de liberté créatrice
en 2008 il devient directeur de
développement chez une grande entreprise
kdv où il passe six ans enfin dave
décide d'ouvrir sa propre entreprise
près de moscou qui démarre la production
en septembre 2015 très vite ses truffes
sont remarqués au kremlin les hauts
fonctionnaires en gouttes au festival se
passe kayaba chilien en 2015 mger
devient fournisseur officiel du festival
en 2017 puis du kremlin tout entier dès
2018 c'est aussi en 2018 que dave des
ménages à kalingrad avec son entreprise
en quête d' avantages fiscaux il réside
actuellement avec sa nouvelle compagne
[Musique]
bayal bienvenue chez moi merci c'est
joli chez toi disons intérieur café je
viens dit théo et si possible quelques
patchs chocolat le chocolat on va on va
arrêter un petit peu là qu'est ce que tu
m'as tu nous as bien nourrir alors ici
c'est chez toi ouais tu as acheté tulle
où l'on ça se passe je loue en est on
est à cinq minutes en vélo de josiane on
est au milieu du parc c'était plus
facile pour toi de louer que d'acheter
peut-être un jour je veux construire ma
propre main propre bâtiment pour les
jeunes puis ça va être un autre endroit
alors c'est plus facile de louer mais
vous vivez à combien ici alors qui est
avec toi ben je vis ici avec cathy
puissant enfin d'accord il ya
une et trois du tronc des enfants vient
de temps en temps ici oui bah soldats
n'auraient elles sont tenues un peu aux
prêtres viennent plus souvent sont à
moscou on vit bien que les immigrants
oui mais voilà quoi mais à moscou c'est
vrai que tu as vécu tu as vécu combien
de temps un masque ou presque avec
des buttes à l'eau de la ville sa part
un maximum 15 minutes tandis qu'à moscou
avec les bouchons des fois c'est pour
deux ans je vois tu as des instruments
de quoi de torture c'est pour ces pour
tracter c'est bien tu manges tout du
chocolat toute la journée quoi tu
t'entraînes il faut se tenir la fois
voilà là tu peux y aller
[Musique]
alors que moi un petit peu ça fait
combien de temps que vous n'êtes que
vous êtes ensemble trois ans ouais ça
qu'on travaille ensemble depuis trois
ans qu'on est ensemble depuis 2 ans et 1
contre et on travaille travaille avec
moi un deuxième et quel est le rôle de
katia dans
l'usiné deux affaires tout alors c'est
pas une grosse entreprise puis on s'est
pas les tâches comment on peut c'est pas
trop dur de travailler ensemble quand on
est un couple non je pensais au départ
je pensais que c'était impossible puis
maintenant mais avec 4,6 et c'est bien
quand sont toujours à ce moment on est
ensemble du matin au soir et pour toi ce
n'est pas difficile travailler ensemble
dv passionné par son travail c'est ce
qui est le plus impressionnant donc ceux
qui sont autour se passionne aussi
avec qui est le chef là bas et qui est
le chef ici je pense que c'est toi le
chef partout dave toute la journée tu
lui fais du chocolat il y avait odeur de
chocolat et à la maison comment ça se
passe
tutu blanc tu manges géant du chocolat
la maison oui oui parle qu un fan mais
je me suis cramé cas surtout la fin de
semaine si je peux au travail challans
qu il ya un accord c'est de l'huile in
drogue
je colle à qu'est ce que vous faites de
votre temps libre
on va en voir la mer ouais
on se repose un peu
nous avons décidé de profiter du temps
d'aller nous promener avec dave dans une
zone naturelle classée au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco nous sommes sur
l'isthme de courlande une flèche
littoral qui sépare la lagune de
courlande de la mer baltique sur une
centaine de kilomètres se trouve cette
étroite avancé de terre couverte de
forêts et de sable à son point le plus
étroit cette bande de terre ne fait que
400 mètres de largeur nous sommes
maintenant au bord de la mer baltique
la mer la mer la mer c'est pas loin
c'est une demi-heure du travail tu viens
souvent ici ouais des deux côtés de
kaliningrad ses 100 kilomètres de chaque
côté ça va ça que la métropole en
cinquième et en lituanie puis c'est
c'est la plage il ya pas beaucoup de
personnes
on ramasse des morceaux d'ambré par
terre ah oui il ya de nouveau c'est ça
si on parle un peu de son pays est ce
que
est ce que le canard est mort oui oui
j'aurais depuis que j'ai démarré mon
entreprise ça fait ça fait cinq ans je
suis pas allé avant j'allais police et
tu as tu encore de la famille là-bas
c'est ça j'ai mon père ma mère ma soeur
mais grâce à la demande comment ça a été
de d'expliquer à tes parents que tu tu
partais en russie
quand je suis en a reçu pour la première
fois j'étais venu
j'ai étudié la théologie oui puis jetée
vieux monastères
puis ensuite ma mère elle avait peur que
je viens de moi alors que je lui dise
que je le relis je me suis fait russell
était là et heureuse
et pourtant tu parles aux russes wells
par le russe n'a pas été trop difficile
la première non j'ai appris je pense que
c'est une question de motivation puis
d'intérêts j'ai appris le russe de façon
autonome très vite un puits
j'avais un petit lycée c'était le rush à
90 jours ouais c'est un petit livre
comme ça je sais pas si tu as remarqué
ça avec tes enfants bon les russes que
je tenais remarques d'un accent étranger
mes enfants ne ne crois pas que je
crois que je me fous de leur
continent
et expliquant quelque chose est-ce que
c'est compliqué de créer une entreprise
en russie
oui c'est compliqué mais je pense y
compris qu'un partout mais il ya
beaucoup de chance
si ça marche bien dans une entreprise
faux pas prendre tous en génie si ça
marche mais faut pas se décourager
je crois énormément ce que je fais j'ai
un bon produit tu penses que tu aurais
réussi à faire la même chose au canada
je sais pas
je reste un pays quand même
d'entrepreneurs au québec à celle ci
s'était pas un projet que j'avais tout
dans ma tête quand j'avais 15 ans c'est
venu petit à petit qui s'adapte aux
situations peut-être que s'arrêter
complètement différent canada
peut-être que ça aurait été mieux
peut-être que sar est impossible ça
prend beaucoup plus de fonds pour
démarrer
par contre c'est plus facile de se
financer peut-être avec les ligues en
russie et maintenant tu considères que
la russie c'est ton pays
ou
ccc mon pays aussi
[Musique]
est ce qu'il y as que tu vois des points
communs entre les canadiens et les
russes ont beaucoup plus que les
canadiens voudraient lemaitre mais je
pense que les gens sont très très très
semblables qu'est ce que la russie peut
apporter au canada
des banques ailleurs
un trait de caractère des russes que tu
n'apprécies pas
des fois ils sont plus secs direct
battue c'est leur idée de charlotte chez
ce qu'ils ont derrière la tête
alors je sirène inverse un trait de
caractère que tu apprécies des russes
l'honnêteté
la franchise ouais est ce que le
chocolat doit être amer ou sucrés il
doit te plaire pour toi quel est le
meilleur chocolat
le mieux
un grand merci pour le temps que tu as
passé avec ton excellent chocolat je
souhaite une longue route en tout cas
merci beaucoup oui ben chocolat pour la
dernier pour la route alors oui
merci
[Musique]
et voilà notre émission touche à sa fin
nous l'avons passé avec un québécois
dave rogers qui nous a fait découvrir
son excellent chocolat et la russie
baltique de nouveaux lieux de nouvelles
personnalités toutes aussi intéressantes
vous attendent je vous dis à très
bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]